you are one of the I think five highest
paid female executives in the country
what does that sound like to someone
who's from a small town one of six kids
former cheerleader from Palestine
Indiana I absolutely never think about
it until a moment like this yeah now I
really don't because I didn't do it I've
never done anything in my life for money
I've never asked for money I've never
taken a job for money and I would not
even accept an offer letter from Apple
until I knew I wanted to do the job and
I was clear in my mind what the mission
what the opportunity was and only once I
had total peace and it was clear in my
mind then it was like okay but you
understand why it matters or is of
interest to people because of a pay gap
that still exists and also because
there's so few women in Silicon Valley
especially in the executive ranks yeah
and you know what the funny thing is and
there are though I mean even at Apple I
mean there's a woman Dierdre who heads
up Ops for Apple over 20 years and a
woman who is mt is a vice president for
20 30 years I mean the woman who heads
up Human Resources my retail Stephanie
human resource partner I mean there are
you you know and I think I think that
that hurts me that bothers me but
there's that impression only we look at
like the top yeah you know but if I
could tell you how many women executives
and for years they've made Apple and I
wish I wish that I wish there would be a
huge interview and a huge focus on that
because it's a it's bigger than what
people write about